[Musique]
sors tout de suite de la chanson le type
avec la capuche grise
je suis la chef d'agence
je suis à Estelle Valérie une fois
qu'ils sont tous dehors
les fermer toutes les portes vous avez
compte les portes
on a aussi le FBI et le bureau de
Géorgie bref tout le monde est là
je suis
désolé je suis le sergent Bernard tout
le monde va bien chez vous tout ira bien
si regarde son canon personne ne serait
blessé j'ai une bombe sur moi et je suis
prêt à tuer toutes les personnes dans
cette banque si jamais
maintenant
vous êtes
désolé pour vous Madame OK
[Musique]
je veux la récupérer moi aussi j'ai eu
quelques problèmes avec le bureau des
vétérans je voudrais que vous relâchiez
une des otages non je veux que tout le
monde sache ce qui se passe ici je veux
des camions de pompiers des caméras de
chaîne d'infos vous avez toute mon
attention je vous
je veux pas que la banque me rembourse
voilà ce que je vous propose entre
frères d'armes j'ai pas beaucoup de
temps malgré ce que vous croyez les
sniper sont en place
pour obtenir la tension
donc tout ce que vous allez dire tout ce
que vous allez faire
c'est important vous êtes important
tout ce qu'il vous faut c'est pas faire
de vagues
[Musique]
pas faire de vagues
vous avez déjà été braqué une fois ça
c'est bien fini
[Musique]